>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washing, DC.
>> All right.
Hi, everybody.
Welcome back to the Green Stage.
I am here to introduce
the next program,
which will honor student finalists
and winners of the Library
of Congress A Book That Shaped Me:
Letters About Literature
Summer Writing Contest.
We are delighted that today's
contest program will be emceed
by Eun Yang, who is no stranger
to the National Book Festival.
Miss Yang is an Emmy
award-winning television anchor
for NBC4 Washington.
In addition to anchoring
news for today,
she files compelling
community stories about people
and organizations important
to the Washington area,
and has been an author
introducer at the book festival
for the past seven years.
She's also the mother of
three and a proponent of books
and reading for young people.
So let's put our hands
together for Miss.
Eun Yang [applause].
>> Eun Yang: Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for that
wonderful introduction.
Hi, everyone.
It's great to be here
and great to see you.
I love all the bean bags
they set up, making it nice
and comfy for a great event today.
The National Book Festival
is, indeed,
one of my most favorite
events every single year.
And I am delighted to
host this essay contest
for the second year in a row.
You know, writing is really hard.
I know it.
But let me tell you, it
will take you places.
In every profession you do, whatever
you pursue, writing is critical.
It is critical in my job.
And I tell my kids.
I have two kids who would
prefer math and science.
I say, listen, you're going
to have to do research papers,
you're going to have
to go to college.
So you have to write
and be a good writer.
So the fact that you spent your
summer doing this is so impressive,
and I'm so proud of each and every
one of you who've submitted essays
to this contest this year.
I am joined on the stage
today by David Rubenstein.
And, you know, the host said
that I do a lot of stories
about the community, and he
is definitely someone we talk
about a lot because of
all the charitable work
and all the contributions
he makes to this great city
to keep it running and to
really support arts and culture
and the sort of creative juices
that are flowing in this area.
And so, we really want to
thank him for being here.
He is the lead benefactor
and cochairman
of the National Book Festival.
We have Fred Bowen who
is here again this year.
He's a sports writer
for the KidsPost.
What a cool job that is too, right?
Awesome. Lola Pyne, my friend.
We went to high school
together years ago.
Longer for me.
And Bryonna Head, who works
for the Library of Congress
to manage this wonderful contest.
A Book That Shaped Me was launched
by the Library of Congress in 2012
with DC Public Library and has
since expanded throughout
the mid-Atlantic region.
The contest asks rising 5th and
6th graders, I have one of those,
to reflect on a book that
has shaped their life,
influencing the way they see
themselves, their community
or their world, and students
entered by writing a one-page letter
to their librarian that
they then submit in person
to a participating public library in
Washington, DC, Maryland, Virginia,
Delaware, Pennsylvania
or West Virginia.
It's a really a wide-reaching group
of really talented individuals.
So over the years, we've had
more than a thousand essays
that have been submitted to
more than 350 public libraries
that have signed up to
administer this contest as part
of their summer reading programs.
No summer slide here, right.
The reading is so important.
And we love reading, so it's easy.
Then the essays are judged by
members of the American Association
of School Librarians and later
by a grand prize panel of judges
that are selected by
the Library of Congress
that included children's authors,
educators and library staff.
Fred Bowen is one of the authors
who has written 21 sports-themed
books for children, 21.
That's a lot of writing
and a lot of reading.
It goes together.
He's also been involved
in this essay contest,
A Book That Shaped
Me, six years ago.
And he is here today to
introduce the 2017 finalists
and state winners.
So ladies and gentlemen, a warm
welcome for Fred Bowen please.
[ Applause ]
>> Fred Bowen: All right.
Good morning.
Yeah. I've been here since the
very beginning, six years ago.
And I love the contest
really for few reasons.
And the first reason is
it gets kids to read.
And school is starting now, and
everybody's wondering, well, gee,
how do we get kids
smarter and more educated.
It seems to me that if kids just
read more and schools took more time
for reading, the kids
would get better.
Thank you.
All the other theories, there
much be such a strong correlation
between reading and
academic achievement.
The second thing I like about the
contest is it gets kids writing.
And maybe it's just
because I'm a writer.
And yes, I've written
all those books
and I write a weekly kids sports
column for the Washington Post.
But I don't think you can really
understand something unless you're
able to write about it.
And practicing writing is
such an important thing.
And the final thing that I love
about this contest is
it gets kids thinking.
The reading and the writing leads
to thinking, which is what did I
like about this book, how did this
book change me, how am I going
to be different because
I read this book.
And it seems to me, as I look
around, we need more thinking.
We need a lot more
thinking by everybody.
And the final thing I like
about this essay contest,
every essay had more
than 140 characters.
We need more essays.
We need less Twitter.
All right.
So now, I'm going to read the
names of the finalists by state.
And Lola and Bryonna
-- Oh, one more thing.
I almost forgot this.
And I did it a couple of years
ago and they never forgave me.
Do we have the other
judges in the house?
Maria Salvador, are you
here and can you stand up?
Rachel Walker, and then
Dana, are you here?
Give them a round of applause.
[ Applause ]
All right.
Now, I will read the names of
the finalists by state, and Lola
and Bryonna will hand them
their certificates and awards
as they come up on the stage.
And please, if I pronounce
your name wrong, forgive me.
I have been introduced as Fred Brown
more times than I can tell you.
All right.
First, from the district of
Columbia, Nekole Isaac [applause].
Actually, why don't
we hold the applause
until the very end for everybody.
Sienna Morgan.
And the district winner
Safya Biswal.
Now you can give them some applause.
[ Applause ]
All right.
Here we go.
>> Congratulations.
>> Fred Bowen: Congratulations.
Next is from my state, Maryland.
And all the finalists
are from my town,
Montgomery County public
libraries, where I go all the time.
Rushi Jain, from Germantown Library.
>> Congratulations.
>> Fred Bowen: Josiah
Main, Rockville Library.
>> Congratulations.
>> Thank you.
>> Fred Bowen: Raniya Najih,
from Bethesda Public Library.
>> Congratulations.
>> Fred Bowen: Sidney D Robinson.
And the Maryland winner,
Lily Luther.
>> Congratulations.
[ Applause ]
>> Fred Bowen: All right.
Now the finalists from Virginia:
Devin Dunn, Alexandria Library,
Lucy Garfield, Prince
William Public Library.
>> Congratulations.
>> Fred Bowen: Olivia Hana
Lee, Prince William Public.
>> They sent the -- Okay,
you can go ahead, sweetie.
We'll give it to you.
>> Fred Bowen: Isla Rodriguez,
Richmond Public Library.
Isla, by the way, was also
the Virginia winner last year.
So welcome back.
And the 2017 Virginia
winner, Suzahn Vollstad,
Prince William Public Library.
>> Congratulations.
[ Applause ]
>> Fred Bowen: Cool tie.
I should have worn one, I know.
Now from the state of Delaware:
Catherine Cole, New Castle County,
Kestra Cole, New Castle County,
Maggie Clarke-Fields,
also New Castle County.
Yeah. Kate McGowan, Delaware
Library System Dover Public Library.
And the Delaware winner, Molly
Amerling, Frankford Public Library.
[ Applause ]
Molly was also a Delaware
finalist last year.
So she is back.
Now the finalists from
Pennsylvania: Shannon Connor,
Indian Valley Public Library,
Isabella Peli, York County,
Annabelle Troup, Bucks
County Free Library System,
Eliana Whing, York County.
And the Pennsylvania winner,
Megan S. Garrabrant, Bucks County.
[ Applause ]
You may want to say
hi to her down there.
And now the finalists from
West Virginia: Kathryn Bell,
Cabell County Public Library.
Actually, Kathryn lives in
Ohio, but made the effort to go
in person to West Virginia.
All right.
She kind of furthest
to the party I guess.
Brooke Hayden Carey,
Cabell County Library.
Alivia Harley, Kaylee J. Polk.
And the West Virginia
winner, Alexander Irby.
All right.
Now let's give all the finalists
and state winners a big round
of applause and everyone.
[ Applause ]
I hope everyone who is up on
the stage will keep reading
and keep writing and, most
of all, keep thinking.
All right, thank you.
>> Eun Yang: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
And I really love what
you said, Fred,
about really understanding something
until you've written about it.
And I think that is a big
connection for what we do early
on in our education and later on.
So what he said, keep reading
and writing and thinking.
It's so important.
I really also want to give another
shout out to all the students
who took time out of their summer.
I know summer is a time
for having fun and enjoying
with your family, which
is so awesome.
But to spend time writing about
a topic that is so near and dear,
to be introspective, to think about
who you are and who you want to be,
not just what you want
to be when you grow up.
So big kudos to everyone
who's been recognized.
And I love this contest
because it does reward you
for all your great efforts.
Thank you to all the families who've
made the trip, to the little sisters
and brothers who were
shouting out the names.
I love to see all that.
So thank you again.
Next up, we're going to hear
from the National Book Festivals
Cochairman, Mr. David Rubenstein,
to introduce the grand
prize winners.
A warm welcome [applause].
>> David Rubenstein: Thank you.
So how many of the young adults
or children here actually
want to be here?
Okay. How many really wanted to give
up their Labor Day
weekend to be here?
Be honest.
All right.
How many people here of you can
name the librarian of Congress?
Anybody can name the
librarian of Congress?
Who? Who? The librarian of Congress,
anybody, for a special prize?
Anybody can name the
librarian of Congress?
Who? Okay, come here.
You got it?
>> She got it.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay.
[ Applause ]
All right, here's a
hundred-dollar bill.
>> What?
>> David Rubenstein:
Librarian of Congress.
Remember that name, okay?
Congratulations.
All right.
Carla Hayden, remember that.
Librarian of Congress.
>> Are you giving out prizes?
>> David Rubenstein: More.
Okay. Maybe we'll have
another prize.
Okay. Pay attention.
Okay. So my job is to call
up the grand prize winners
and have them read their essays,
and I'll ask them a question or two.
So first, I'd like to ask the
third-place grand prize winner
and the Pennsylvania state winner,
Megan Garrabrant, to come up
and to read the essay
Courage to Soar.
Okay.
[ Applause ]
Okay. Go ahead.
Read it loud, loud and clear.
>> Megan Garrabrant: Dear librarian,
do you watch the summer Olympics?
I do, especially when the
gymnastics is televised.
My favorite gymnasts in the
2016 Olympics was Simone Biles.
So when my mom told me
about the book "Courage
to Soar," I had to read it.
Here is why Simone's autobiography
is a book that shaped me.
First of all, in both
gymnastics and school,
Simone gave an A plus effort.
I try to do that as often as I can,
but instead of being a gymnast,
I am a swimmer on a
competitive swim team.
Just like Simone, I am much shorter
and smaller in size than so many
of the others in my
swimming age group.
But that doesn't discourage me.
Every time I'm standing on the
block, waiting for the sound
of the bullhorn signaling
to dive into the pool,
I think of Simone's words: "Maybe
because I was always so much smaller
than everyone around me, I had
this fierce drive to prove myself."
Next, Simone writes that her
accomplishments are the result
of her faith and her
family's support.
She was raised by her grandparents
and knew them as mom and dad.
They encourage her to pray and
ask for God's help when needed.
When Simone's gymnastics'
coach, Amy, suddenly quit,
Simone was stunned and panicked.
And she went directly
to her church to pray.
This has often inspired
me to turn to God
when I am feeling blue,
scared, or nervous.
Last of all, Simone
believed in herself even
when her gymnastics routines
didn't go as well as she had hoped.
She tells young athletes that
if you truly believe in yourself
and are willing to put in the
effort, you can achieve anything.
When my swim meet times aren't as
fast as I would like them to be,
I think of these words
and they encourage me
to push myself harder
at upcoming practices.
Simone Biles stood on the
2016 Olympic medal podium
in Rio de Janeiro not
once, but five times.
Her A plus effort, faith
in God, family support,
and belief in herself all
contributed to her success.
As I dive deeper into
the world of swimming,
I will always remember how hard
she worked to reach that podium.
Like Simone, I am being
shaped by her words.
Whatever happened, as
long as I do my best,
I will get up the next
morning still smiling.
Sincerely, Megan Garrabrant.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay.
That was good.
Stay right there.
So my question to you is, how long
did it take you to write this essay?
>> Megan Garrabrant:
I'm not really sure.
>> David Rubenstein: How long?
Speak into the mic.
>> Megan Garrabrant: A day I think.
>> David Rubenstein: A day, think.
Okay. And did you write
it many times,
or did you just do one
draft and that was it?
>> Megan Garrabrant:
I'm not really sure.
>> David Rubenstein:
You're not sure, okay.
And what grade are you in now?
>> Megan Garrabrant: Sixth.
>> David Rubenstein: And do you
want to go to the Olympics yourself?
No, yes?
>> Megan Garrabrant: I'm not sure.
>> David Rubenstein: Not sure, okay.
And do you want to be a gymnast
like the person you wrote about?
>> Megan Garrabrant: I'm a swimmer,
so I want to go there for swimming.
>> David Rubenstein: All right,
you want to be a swimmer.
And you want to be Olympics
swimmer or not really sure?
>> Megan Garrabrant:
I'm not really sure.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay.
All right.
Well, let me give you your prize.
And here it is.
Here it is.
Come on over.
Put this on you.
[ Applause ]
Thank you very much.
Okay. Now which young person
here can name the building,
the main building of the
Library of Congress is named
after somebody, a very
famous person?
Which young person here can name
the person it's named after?
Who? That's right.
Come on up.
I'll give you a prize.
[ Applause ]
Okay. How'd you know that?
All right, here you
go, a hundred dollars.
Thank you.
Okay, next.
The second grand prize
winner is Isla Rodriguez.
She wrote about "Hidden
Figures," by Margot Lee Shetterly.
Would she come up and
read her essay?
[ Applause ]
Okay. Go ahead.
>> Isla Rodriguez: Hidden
Figures, now we know their names.
On February 20th, 1962, the
signals for Friendship 7,
a spacecraft that NASA launched
into the stars, went seismic.
The safety of the ship's
passenger, Colonel John Glenn,
rested on the shoulders of Katherine
Johnson, a colored computer
who worked at Langley Memorial
Aeronautical Laboratory.
She did the calculations
for his return to Earth.
If she got them right, Colonel
Glenn would come back safely.
If she did not, he would
burn up on reentry.
The national held its breath.
Katherine is one of four wonder
women featured in the book
"Hidden Figures" by
Margot Lee Shetterly.
Reading about Mrs. Johnson and the
other three women, Dorothy Vaughan,
Mary Jackson, and Dr.
Christine Darden, inspired me
and made me feel proud
of their work.
For many years, their
work was unknown,
and reading the book
helped me see areas
where I may have been discriminated
against if they had
not worked so hard.
Reading about these hidden figures
raised my bar of expectation
for myself in my career, in my
education and future career.
I met Christine after
hearing her speak
at Ebenezer Baptist Church
in Richmond, Virginia.
She was not in the movie,
so unless you read the book,
Dr. Darden is the one hidden
figure who stays hidden.
She talked about how kids today
don't usually strive their best
in school.
She said math and science
may be difficult,
but studying both will
pay off in the future.
One similarity Dr. Darden and I have
is we both set educational goals
for ourselves and met them.
Dr. Darden decided to get a
PhD in mechanical engineering.
I decided to get scholar roll
for the last marking period
of my 5th grade school year.
Reading the book, I was amazed
that American's could work
so hard and not be known.
I felt angry that Katherine didn't
get credit for her own work.
I felt ashamed that
America discriminated
against African Americans
because of their skin color.
I was also proud of Katherine,
Dorothy and Mary and Christine
because they worked extremely hard
so America could explore
outer space.
Also, I felt strong because I felt
maybe someday I could help continue
the greatness of NASA.
I am a woman of color,
just like them.
They are inspiring and
exceptional at math,
but I personally am
not great at math.
Yet I know I should do my best
because that's what these
ladies would want for me.
When I got a C in math for the
second to last marking period,
I thought, Katherine Johnson
wouldn't want this for me.
I should get an A. And in the
last marking period of 5th grade,
pulled that sucker up to an A.
I felt like I could do anything.
My mom and I read the book together.
We started a Facebook live group
called the Hidden Figure Sisterhood
and held a Facebook live event to
talk about our opinions on the book.
We talked about hidden figures
that we know in our family.
My great grandmother, Annabel
Fay Brown [assumed spelling],
worked in a lab for
more than 25 years
for the United States
Department of Agriculture.
My great aunt Murielle Anne Brown
Nichols [assumed spelling] has
worked at Central Virginia Community
College for more than 40 years.
Today, she is vice president of
academic and student services there.
I feel proud of these two women who
may be hidden figures of the world,
but they're not hidden from me.
On that day, in 1962,
after 14 minutes of agony,
the nation breathed
a huge sigh of relief
when Colonel Glenn's voice was
heard again at mission control.
He splashed down to Earth safely,
and the world knew his name.
Thanks to Margot Lee Shetterly, the
world now knows the work and names
of Katherine Johnson,
Dorothy Vaughan, Mary Johnson,
and Dr. Christine Darden.
Last year, I wanted to be
a civil rights attorney
because if people don't protect our
civil rights, they will deplete.
After reading "Hidden Figures," I
might want to become an astronaut
and do something to change history.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay, great.
So let me ask you a question.
How long did it take
you to write that essay?
>> Isla Rodriguez: About two weeks.
>> David Rubenstein: Two weeks.
And did you rewrite it over and
over again, or was it a first draft?
>> Isla Rodriguez: My
mom edited it for me.
>> David Rubenstein: I see.
>> Isla Rodriguez: And she was at
work and she was extremely busy.
>> David Rubenstein: And
is she a good editor?
Does she know how to edit?
She's a good editor?
>> Isla Rodriguez: Yes.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay.
And whatever happened to John Glenn?
>> Isla Rodriguez: He --
I actually can't remember.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay.
And do you want to be an attorney?
>> Isla Rodriguez: I did.
>> David Rubenstein: And do you
have to go to law school to do that
or you want to go to law school?
>> Isla Rodriguez: I did.
>> David Rubenstein: And you
want to go to law school?
>> Isla Rodriguez: I don't know.
>> David Rubenstein: You don't know.
Okay. Well, if you're going to
be an attorney, it helps to go
to law school usually, but okay.
So why don't you come over
and I'll give you your prize.
[ Applause ]
There you go.
>> Isla Rodriguez: Thank you.
>> David Rubenstein: There you go.
Okay, congratulations.
[ Applause ]
Okay. So now we're ready for
the first grand prize winner,
and that person is Suzahn Vollstad,
who wrote about "A Dog's
Purpose" by Bruce Cameron.
Can Suzahn please come up?
[ Applause ]
>> Suzahn Vollstad: Dear
Librarian, this spring,
I read a book that made me
see the purpose of my life,
my brother's life and
a therapy dog's life.
Ever since I heard the movie
"A Dog's Purpose" was coming
out, I wanted to see it.
But then I heard that
there was a book.
And I knew you should read the
book before you watch the movie.
So that is exactly what I did.
I have never read a book
so fast in my whole life.
I couldn't put it down.
And when it ended, I felt like
it should have never ended.
It is one of my all-time
favorite books.
"A Dog's Purpose" is about a dog
that keeps on being reincarnated.
Throughout each of his lives,
he/she went through difficult
circumstances and experiences.
Although he didn't see the
greater purpose at the time,
he later realized that each of those
different difficulties prepared him
for something important in
the next life or this life.
So far, in my 11 years, I have had
some very difficult experiences
that have felt sad and unfair.
This book got me to thinking that
there must be a greater purpose
to my experiences as well.
For example, I watched my
brother almost die three times.
With my own two eyes, I watched him
suffer through multiple strokes,
nonstop seizures, and more.
Why should a 7-year-old
witness a 3-year-old boy go
through all of this?
After reading "A Dog's
Purpose," I can now see
that there must have been a
greater purpose to it all.
And I've spent some time trying
to piece it all together.
Of course, a dog is involved
with the brightest part
of my brother's story as well.
After about two months in the
hospital with nonstop seizures,
a life-changing moment occurred.
We had been given the worst
news possible about my brother.
My whole family from Norway
flew in to say goodbye
because we didn't think
my brother would make it.
But two therapy dogs
had another idea.
Almost as soon as those magical
little dogs passed my brother's
room, he stopped seizing.
The whole time he was with them,
he didn't have a single seizure.
He cuddled with the dogs and
almost spoke a whole sentence
in the first time in ages.
Maybe the purpose of those
dogs was to save my brother.
Living at Children's
National Medical Center
for five months watching
my brother, my best friend,
deteriorate beside me in the
hospital bed scarred me for life.
But now as I look back on it,
I realize that the entire experience
could have actually had a greater
purpose in my life
and my brother's life.
Maybe I'm supposed to inspire or
help other kids who have siblings
with special needs, seizures
or mitochondrial disease.
This got me to thinking
that I should go
to the children's support
group for seizures or volunteer
at the Children's National
Medical Center.
I once went to a seizure
support group when I was 7.
I was terrified.
I've come out on the other side now
of my brother's strokes and seizures
and I've accepted his diagnosis.
As awful as it all had been,
well, there was a bigger purpose
in the difficulties my
brother and I went through.
I can now help other
terrified siblings.
Reading "A Dog's Purpose"
helped me to start thinking
of the greater purpose in my
life difficulties and experiences
and start to be more
accepting of them.
I believe that those therapy
dogs made a huge impact
on the outcome of my brother.
And this book helped me to see the
event from a different perspective,
through the perspective
of a therapy dog's life.
Moreover, I've finally found a
different perspective and purpose
for my own life situations
that have been painful.
I will help other siblings with this
disease, and I hope to someday buy
and train a therapy
dog who can always be
with my brother and protect him.
Sincerely, Suzahn Vollstad.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay.
Great. Let me ask her questions.
So what grade are you in?
>> Suzahn Vollstad:
I'm going into sixth.
>> David Rubenstein:
You're going into sixth.
And how long did it take
you to write this essay?
>> Suzahn Vollstad:
About two days maybe.
>> David Rubenstein: Two days.
Okay. And what do you want
to be when you grow up?
>> Suzahn Vollstad: I want to be a
veterinarian or a PA like my mom.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay.
Is your brother here?
>> Suzahn Vollstad: Yes, he is, in
the wheelchair right over there.
>> David Rubenstein: All right.
All right.
Well, congratulations
to both of you.
And come on over and
I'll give you your prize.
Congratulations.
>> Suzahn Vollstad: Thank you.
>> David Rubenstein: Okay.
Thank you.
Back to you.
>> Eun Yang: Thank you so
much and congratulations
to all the essay winners
and everyone who wrote
and spent time this summer writing.
And what a fun surprise
for those people
who knew the answers
to those two questions.
Congratulations to you, too.
That's terrific.
These are such powerful
essays, and they make you think
about what Suzahn wrote about, your
purpose in life, the greater purpose
in what we do every single day.
I think reading and
writing helps you get closer
to figuring those things out.
And I think that's why
books are so magical.
They provide you with adventures.
They provide you with insight.
And you get to meet people
from around the world
without ever having
to leave your home.
And that is one of the reasons
why I truly love reading.
I have three kids.
I don't get to do it as
much as I'd like to anymore,
but still at the top of my
list of one of my passions.
And I love the book festival
for supporting those endeavors
and supporting the
writing part of it.
The writing is hard, I know it.
But it's such an important
part of your learning process
and a growing process
as an individual.
So once again, thank you
so much to Mr. Rubenstein,
Mr. Bowen, Lola, Bryonna.
Thank you so much for being here.
Another round of applause to all
the talented student writers.
[ Applause ]
Thank you so much.
And to all of you here this
afternoon, including the students
and the families, the
teachers, the librarians,
all who make this program possible.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for supporting and
joining the Library of Congress
in nurturing this wonderful
culture of reading and writing.
We honor you and your
accomplishments,
and we are so grateful
for your commitment
to scholarship and to education.
Thank you, everyone.
Continue to enjoy this
wonderful event.
And we'll see you next year.
Have a great day.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.